le blanc rouge dans le ciel de la
croisette
et instar du jour ça lui comme il se
doit par la patrouille de france
à son arrivée déjà une ovation à la
hauteur de l'événement tom cruise a
porté de celle fille et qui s'attardent
longuement auprès de ses fans tom cruise
qui a profité qui a provoqué un
véritable mouvement de foule sur la
croisée de pensée pour cette dame qui
s'est fait littéralement broyé
[Musique]
elle c'est la pire
g
c'est là qu'elle bat bête mais c'est
celle qui est entourée
à la halle et à la photo de tom cruise
je vais mourir
rocheland les charmants charme ans et il
est adorable
je la met à côté de moi la place de mon
mari
tom cruise qui n'est pas reparti les
mains vides il a reçu une palme d'or
d'honneur surprise pour l'ensemble de sa
magnifique carrière
moins de chance comme cette dame
[Musique]
tourne autour de son petit nombril
c'est au tour de notre nombril en fait
des t-shirts des tasses des flasques à
vodka dans cette boutique du centre
ville de moscou vladimir poutine est
omniprésent
il coûte combien ces t-shirts 11 euros
vous en vendez beaucoup oui les t-shirts
poutine c'est ce qui se vend le mieux
cellule lapsus virale de ces dernières
heures celui de george w.bush la langue
de l'ancien président des états unis a
fourché hier lors d'un discours à dallas
le résultat est une absence de freins et
de contrepoids en russie
et la décision d'un seul homme de lancer
une invasion totalement injustifiée et
brutale de l'irak je veux dire de
l'ukraine bush a mis son erreur sur le
compte de ses 75 ans de quoi faire rire
son auditoire
depuis ce que le kremlin appel
l'opération spéciale en ukraine le
président russe est devenu un paria sur
la scène internationale
mais ici sa popularité reste solide il
est célébré comme une icône
nous le suivrons jusqu'au bout
nous sommes des patriotes
il a fait tellement de choses pour nous
pour prouver qu'il n'est pas extrême il
a employé un argument qu'on n'avait pas
entendu depuis nadine morano et son ami
noir
il intervient lui même bien simplement
que le jeu de la dédiabolisation du
rassemblement national d'une personne
donc on peut dire autant qu'on veut
qu'on n'est pas extrême à partir du
moment appartient à un parti extrémiste
ça ça restera un goupillon photos de ma
femme merci
le candidat de la 3e circonscription du
rhône gérard bolouri s'est alors défendu
en montrant une photo de sa femme
d'origine rwandaise et à la couleur de
peau noire un geste prémédité qui a
surpris voire indignés les invités sur
le plateau soit parce que la vie privée
dans l'année de l'arrivée on est dans un
débat politique alors un candidat et
rennes fait polémique en brandissant la
photo de sa femme noire pour prouver
qu'il n'est pas raciste on a aussi le
désolé je suis nul comme les autres
en économisant sur des sur quoi
justement
l'immigration
c'est à dire
plus rien changé par un chauffard et je
suis désolé allez vous installer glande
avec robben et qui pendent